that's New Jersey okay
built the scale Kodiak Island and they
have I'll get this this is what kills me
they have eight point eight million
people in New Jersey on purpose so guess
what city I'm in Washington DC our
nation's capital it is the seat of power
for the United States of America our
country may be young but what a history
we have so join me as the Beast checks
out the beauty
so here I am you know sue Aikens life
below zero from Catholic River Camp way
up north the nation's capital the
absolute seat of power the state capitol
building this whole area here Senators
Congressmen
laws bantered about changed exchanged
things voted in I'm hoping today to meet
with some of my own Alaska state
representatives very impressed very
powerful and quite a thing to see but
now let's see if I can get to talking
about it with them hello senator
Murkowski how are you doing here see I I
can identify the Alaskan cuz you're
wearing your nice car hurt you represent
especially with this outfit 122-pound
gold nugget on the Yukon River like you
doing what it was we're not that far
apart because I get here is like okay I
have got to get back home I've got to
breathe the air
that's real I gotta talk to people that
are real show me where you are
from my window I can see these ranges
Sadler opiates and whatnot so I am right
about you and I'm then come on straight
down now over this way people assume I
don't like people because I live alone
I'm like no living and that's how I live
I'm gregarious I love people yeah I got
to know that there's an exit strategy
tell me I'm gonna be here and then out
on the 16th I can handle anything
between that and then I got to go touch
the soil even when I was five four or
five years old when people asked me in
the mid sixties what do you want to be
when you grow up I always said
lighthouse keeper
I've always been an extreme isolationist
any happy about it you're really very
lucky to have that and to be in the
spaces that you are you present to me
the spirit of the Alaska that I believe
in and that means a lot to me Washington
DC I don't equate it with like hanging
out at the beach and having fun I equate
it with
history knowledge seeing amazing things
but you know it should be filled with
politicians at our head in the game
effecting change as remote as I am it's
not for everybody but I'd the job that
you do and the representation you give
enables me to do project thank you I
know we're busy
thank you so much I able to meet you it
was really great meeting senator
Murkowski and congressman young and
getting to talk about where we live
Alaska and the different experiences
we've had it was kind of like getting a
little taste of home in the lower 48
getting to talk to them in person was a
real treat and I saw that no matter
where we are
Alaskans never forget where they come
from I'm gonna shake your hand I'm a
hugger if you don't mind sweetie I am 82
years old I can't get up I don't either
you